>>SENATO T HE SURE
CUE WARS.
AKING ISSU A EOHAT R'S ST
>> AILUG FAIBALLET
PLAYED VIOLIN, I ALSO MARCHED
R EQTY
BEEN
DEINDOM N AGE.
WHEN I WAS 6 YEARS OLD, ONE OF
MCCIDENT THAT
LEFT H PARALYZED.
AGAIN.
BUT SHE TAPPED INTO MY FAMILY'S
PRIDE TO GET BAC FEET.
EVTU STANDING AT THE ALTAR
TO MAR MHEMOM.WITH SUCH POWERFU
TOP OF MY CLASS.I NEEDED MOWN N
G WI A
RECRUITER, I F IT.
Y TORO MR STRENGTH
ON
ANSWERED MY CALLING.
MILITA TRUY  ACTUATO SER
I WANT YOU T THEEXAS REPUE ON
>> WHAT WE'RE YI IS WE'R
PANSIES.OY TMEN TR IT INTO, FRA
ISO HE BADUYS TRIK I AMERICA.
PEOPLE S
MILITARY BECAUSE THEY WANTO
KEEPFEEYONT A
LE E AND P DAISIES BACK AND FOR.
I DON'T CARERE A IA.TER.
THE NATION, NDATION
AND TRAIN TO DO TH DIFFERENTPE
DUCKWORTH, AN IRAQ WAR VETERAN
AND  RE WITH THEN DOING PUSHUPA
A WOKE MILITARY ISA.
SE AYOUR
COLLEAGUE.EL SAY THA THE MILITAM
E SUPREMACIS
MB, HE IRETWEETINAANDA TO .
LII WOULD LIKE TO HEI'M WILLING
TO MET
ABT THE VIBO RPORAL WAS EMASCULT
MILITARY INT
PANSIES?
IT'S THE FACGR OEI
CLASINING
MILITARY?
OVERCAME THEM IWHO OSING  USE K
OATH TO PROTT ANCONSTITUTIONE U
STATES?
WIIN HEAR FROM
SE, WHICGSR MILI
P
BE AUSE I DON'
CD A GOOD REASON.
FRANKLY, HE IS WAY MARK .RY IHE
VERY BEST TOOI SEEMS
TO ME THATS CORP IONG THE BEST.
, I JUST WANT TO
WEBSITES, CHANNELSCICHANNELS, TS
D TO AND
E T.MEAN, THSTE PROUD.
THELI
RE
THAT -- , HE'S -- HE'S
R IT, TH. YEA HA UNITED STENAS
STITARY,HEE MILI, THAT HASROERIE
TOOMENT AND INS ALONWITH SO MANP
TOISTHE AMERICSETEUBLICANS,
INCLUDING MR. CRUZJUENT VERY CL
AC JANUARY N
6th.
BY THE WAY, A AN
TRUMP PROPAGANDA WD TH FM HAOP E
ISG TO DISACS D MOT  A STORMCRAA
OH, YE,  GOINGO WHITE SUPREMACIE
HE'S AT IT.AMEFUL.
>> YEAH.
WHO'SR TED CRUZ AA BAME MASNI H
NEWS.
IS APP THE SIZE OF ITS
L FROM
$2.25  T.7 TRILLION.WEHAS BEEN
REPUBLICANS.
YOEATO TREDUCTION.
WL,M WILLING TO WORTH MLL ACRO
AISLE TONFHE.
NEED ME TO THTABLE.THINK
EFFOTHE OMEWHAT CONCERNED ABOUT
DISTANCE EDUCATION.
WE HAVE OVER 20 ION OLDS I
ACCESS TO BROADBAND.Y ABOUT MO
CAPE
>> SENATORI
APTE YOU WANT TO M, BUT I HE
TELL THEAR YOU'RE  SOMEHOW HA
SOMEONE EDN RE AN IRAQANW OF SEG
, HE FLED TO UL
SERVED BE IN THE
PRETTY TOUGH MNOW, I SOME
ALL DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS  ME IU
FRAT
BELIEVFE
NSTU EACH , T
WHEN I WAS SITNGN MYG  D
AFTER WE WERSHOT ASK WHO CAMTOR
OR HOW T
ALL I CARED ABOUT IS THEY WERE
THERE THCAN